well at the starways we heard John
Bercow the Speaker of the House
opening the proceedings and basically
clarifying a matter of record he was
saying that as the Supreme Court
decision yesterday was that prorogation
the suspension of Parliament had never
happened it was unlawful that word
should be expunged from the
parliamentary record he said that now it
should be recorded that Parliament had
been adjourned
from the evening of the 9th of September
the 10th as when they went away that was
now what it would say in the
parliamentary record then we had the
first of these urgent questions that
we're likely to hear today as he said
it's from Johanna cherry the Scottish
National Party MP who was involved in
the legal cases that the Supreme Court
has been hearing she was asking Jeffrey
Cox the Conservative MP who's also the
Attorney General about the advice that
the government had received and and
given in their arguing for prorogation
now what Jeffrey Cox said was that all
of this advice was set out in or the
government legal case was set out in the
hearing put before the Supreme Council
that he oversaw that legal counsel and
if he was called on to resign every time
he lost a case then he would never have
had any legal practice at all he used to
be a lawyer he said that he was
disappointed that the Supreme Court took
a different view from the other courts
in the country but he accepted the
decision legally he said the matter is
settled now what he did say was which
was interesting was that he would
consider whether the public interest
required any public disclosure of the
advice that had been given to the
government's on the matter he said this
was under consideration he went on
though to praise the judiciary said that
judges are impartial and in a friend
independent the finest one of the finest
judiciary's in the world that puts him
separately to Jacob Riis
another key government figure who said
that the Supreme Court's decision
amounted essentially to a constitutional
coup at Rory
it is Wednesday normally that would be
Prime Minister's Questions which most
people around the world are familiar
with that
raucous weekly event in the houses of
parliament no Prime Minister's Questions
today however Boris Johnson may be
coming to address Parliament a little
later we understand yes that is not
likely to be for a few hours time though
we have a number of ministerial
statements five in total scheduled for
today and Boris Johnson's is going to be
number four in that list and that's not
expected till about 15 GMT so few hours
from now before that we will have
ministerial statements on the collapse
of Thomas Cook the travel company will
have ministerial statements from Michael
go talking about brexit readiness one
from Dominic Robb talking about Iran
then we have the Prime Minister
following the Prime Minister we will
have the leader of the House Jacob Riis
mark so that is the order of events in
Parliament today all remaining thanks al
Jazeera has already challenged their
live in Westminster